hi my lord thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning you were chief of
staff during theresa may's reign when
she was a conservative uh prime minister
um would this have happened under your
watch
i don't think it would have happened
under teresa's watch now
i don't think it would have happened
under any of the other prime ministers i
can think of during my lifetime
and i thought that the report yesterday
was pretty grim reading okay
um it obviously told us a number of
things that we already knew but to me
the two new things
were evidence of
officials in number 10 knowing that what
was going on was wrong that phrase you
mentioned a few minutes ago we think
we've got away with it
and also the frankly shocking
uh reporting of of cleaners and security
staff being abused and i can tell you my
two years in that building
doing a very difficult job under
enormous pressure i cannot tell you how
supportive
the security staff the cleaners the
catering staff the judy clarks were of
me and i find it shocking that staffing
number ten can have behaved towards them
in that way
um steve barkley telling us this morning
it's a warren it's a small building it's
very difficult to know what is going on
unless you are in the room
uh was that your view when you were
there so it is a bit of a warrant but
you know we had we've had whistleblower
evidence the panorama program the other
night of officials in number 10 saying
the prime minister saw these drinks
going on sometimes he joined in
sometimes he didn't but he was aware
of exactly what was happening and i
think one of the real problems he's
going to have now is whether people are
going to say well actually some of your
statements to the house of commons
expressing surprise of these allegations
you were misleading the house because
you you were at some of them and other
than you were clearly aware that what
was going on
we're hearing um that wine time friday
was at 4 00 pm every uh friday um had
been a regular occurrence in downing
street for some time did it happen when
you were there
yeah so sometimes the comms team would
have a would have a drink on a friday
afternoon i don't think there's anything
wrong with that in a normal working
environment but the key point here is
that this was a pandemic and that the
government had changed the rules for all
of us and told us
that meeting people other than strictly
necessary for work purposes wasn't
allowed so
you know obviously when i was at number
10 there was a work christmas party
sometimes on a friday evening people
would have a drink together after work
nothing wrong with that at all the point
here is that the situation was different
the prime minister
made some draconian restrictions on all
our lives and now we discover that he
and the team in number 10 weren't
following the rules that everyone else
was being required to find
um
talk to me about martin reynolds he was
the private secretary to the prime
minister um he's still a civil servant
um he seems to be copying it
as far as the whatsapp groups and etc
are concerned in the report from sue
gray um suggestions that he may well
become an ambassador in saudi arabia how
can that be reasonable when we saw what
happened to allegra stratton
well look i don't know martin and i
don't i don't want him to be the full
guide for all of this process i think
he's he's got some real questions to
answer about some of the material that's
come forward but in the house yesterday
the prime minister said all of the
senior management at number 10 has
changed well that's true apart from him
and you know if you look at the the
police
fines okay we obviously don't know all
the names of the individuals but there's
something pretty distasteful that it
appears to be the case that fairly
junior officials
have borne the brunt of most of these
fines when they were attending events
that were organized and attended by
sometimes the prime minister and other
senior political advisors and officials
in number 10.
who should be the full guide you think
i've been my i made my view clear before
i think the prime minister has fallen
well below the standards that we all
have a right to expect to him and from a
simple moral point of view something
like 60 of the british population thinks
he should resign and i am i am one of
them
i also think pragmatically from the
conservative party's point of view he's
not going to be able to recover his
standing with the electorate and if they
carry on without a change then i fear
they're looking towards a defeat of the
next election
um
can you see a scenario my lord in which
um he will resign or will he be that a
slippery piglet that david cameron often
spoke of
yeah i can't i can't see this i don't
see any prospect at all of him resigning
over this there was a lot of talk of
apology yesterday but if you actually
watch the press conference yesterday
afternoon he doesn't really think he's
done anything wrong now he was saying
well i think i was right to go to these
leading dudes despite the fact that you
know he put in place
regulations that were stopping some of
your viewers being at the deathbed of
dying relatives
so i'm afraid i don't think there's any
real contrition there and i don't see
any prospect at all of him resigning so
it's either going to be conservative mps
deciding that he should go or it's going
to be a decision for all of us at the
next election
um i know you've got a meeting so we'll
have to go muller but i just one final
question if i may uh what about if the
standards committee finds against him
so i think if he's found to have misled
the house i would hope k that that would
be enough to drive conservation peace to
act but um we'll have to see because i
if i've spoken to you a couple of months
ago i would have told you that the
police finding him and finding that he'd
broken the law would have been enough
and it turned out that that wasn't
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time to join us we do
appreciate it my pleasure